willful blindness to Trump's triumph and
how the FBI and DOJ can stop the
bleeding that's the focus of tonight's
angle would handle things under this
hypothetical Hillary Clinton not Donald
Trump won the presidency in 2016 now I
realize that's terrifying to contemplate
but bear with me for just a sec
now imagine that bill is too old to
chase interns so she isn't distracted by
any new scandals and somehow during her
first year in office hillary oversees a
stock market rocketing up there's a big
drop in unemployment including among
minority workers and imagine this
imagine consumer confidence business
investment even wages in certain sectors
all up
imagine Hillary announcing that dozens
of American run businesses are bringing
jobs back to the United States they're
doling out thousand dollar $2,000
bonuses to thousands and thousands of
employees and let's just say that
Republican leaders respond to this news
by calling that money crumbs and it's
all just a gimmick meanwhile imagine
President Clinton renegotiating
important trade deals and taking
unilateral action to level the playing
field for American manufacturers and
workers now by the way I actually
remember when both Hillary and Barack
Obama we're running for president in
2008 and back then they both sounded a
lot more like Trump than Trudeau on
NAFTA you will notify Mexico and Canada
NAFTA is gone in six months we will opt
out of NAFTA unless we renegotiate it I
think actually senator Clinton's answer
on this one is right I think we should
use the hammer of potential opt-out I
don't even remember that I do
now imagine Hillary Clinton targeting
illegal immigrant criminals felons who
are endangering dangering they're mostly
Hispanic neighborhoods
imagine if thanks to the military
planning under commander-in-chief
Clinton we had smashed Isis and driven
him out of Syria well we all
on the economy especially what the press
and the Democrats would be saying and it
wouldn't sound like this the American
people are deeply concerned about the
decline of the American middle class
Republicans need to look in the mirror
think about the damage that they are
causing to the middle class our economy
President Trump
consistently points to a one highlight a
strong economy it was a good year but
maybe not as good as President Trump
wants you to think Oh Chuck amazing now
not that liberals care they not only
don't you know give Trump credit for his
policies or any rework trade deals or
moves on deregulation yes they're
actually some Dems even trying to give
Obama credit for all of 2017 s good
economic news he thinks for a history
started from the day he became president
when in fact you know he inherited good
conditions I thought Barack Obama did
turn around the economy to bring it back
from the precipice and ask for some
tough action mr. Trump inherited a
economy that was in full recovery for
blacks and whites from President Obama
now he's taking credit for the you know
picking up somebody at the end of a trip
that somebody else drove the trip
somebody else drove the trip I don't
even know what he's talking about and to
add insult to injury even while business
leaders do credit Trump's tax cut with
economic growth and all the deregulation
what's the big business story of today
well here it is a new Reuters poll
claiming that just 2 percent of
Americans have gotten a raise a bonus or
other benefit from Trump's tax cuts okay
kids here's a lesson from Laura you
usually get a benefit from a tax cut
when you pay your taxes no everyone is
going to benefit except for upper income
earners hello and from the Trump tax
plan and they're gonna see more money in
their pockets come April when most
people pay their taxes most people don't
play quarterly pay quarterly and so
we're gonna see if at that point
Reuters runs
another poll just to see if people are
happier or benefiting now a far more
telling survey from the National
Association of Business Economics finds
that companies say sales and profits
rose at the end of last year and nearly
half of the respondents say they're now
paying more in wages and in salaries to
their employees this is news that we've
been waiting for and that will benefit
workers long-term it's about time people
had a raise
now I promise you if Hillary Clinton had
had this record the praise would be
deafening on the eve of her State of the
Union meanwhile the media spent the day
blaming the real president for the
voluntary resignation of FBI deputy
director Andrew McCabe the president
played this very active public role in
pressuring the Justice Department to get
rid of the case so far the White House
is saying the president was not involved
in this was not pushed at all Jake it
seems hard to believe that this is yet
another instance of the president
bullying and pressuring law enforcement
agents who is concerned about
investigating him is anybody safe in the
Justice Department my god is anyone safe
from media bias at NBC that's my
question here's the only problem with
that lovely little scenario they painted
there's no evidence to indicate that
Trump is responsible for the McCabe
resignation and do we really want a
deputy director of the FBI
who's so afraid that he has to resign if
he's totally in the right of course we
don't White House spokeswoman Sarah
Huckabee Sanders said this you say
definitively that the President did not
play a role in Andrew Houston
yes I didn't say the president wasn't
part of this decision-making process now
a more likely theory I think is that
mccabe himself along with his previous
boss Jim Comey are actually to blame for
this early retirement now given McCain's
partisan ties via his wife to Hillary's
uh you know best friend Terry McAuliffe
well he shouldn't have had been been
within a hundred yards of either the
Hillary email or the Trump Russia
investigations not with that close tie
remember McKay's wife received a five
hundred thousand dollar donation from
Terry McAuliffe's PAC for her failed
political campaign now given this he
should have removed himself or recused
himself from both probes and there is a
New York Times report tonight suggesting
that FBI director Christopher Rea was
concerned about the findings of a
forthcoming government investigation
into the FBI and into McCabe's conduct
that's the Inspector General's report
and the time source said that the
director and McCabe had a frank
conversation about that report and
apparently a demotion was discussed for
McCabe now whatever the explanation for
McCabe's departure I say this it's about
time there's a larger point being lost
in the McCabe blame game the president
is actually trying to restore confidence
in law enforcement institutions that I
think for a long time have been used as
political instruments are a lot of great
rank-and-file people of course
overwhelming majority but when the
leadership appears to have a political
axe to grind
nobody is served by that so it's time to
cleanse the upper tiers of the Justice
Department and the FBI of all
partisanship it's critical sessions
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
maybe the next one on the chopping block
he reportedly reviewed and approved that
FISA application to surveil the Trump
campaign and we understand it looks like
it was based on that phony Clinton
funded Russian dossier and of course
anti-trump partisans
Jeanne REE and Andrew Weissman should be
immediately terminated from the
investigation as well before any more
damage is done to the credibility of
both the FBI and the Justice Department
and that's the angle